an assembly of top global leaders un
secretary-general ban ki-moon was one of
the first arrivals of the International
Conference on aid for Afghanistan and
spoke with optimism Afghanistan
government under the leadership of
President Ghani and see you after
Abdullah have been making impressive
Luke form the development plans to
change the lives of people for Afghan
President Ashraf Ghani it means
financial help to the tune of more than
12 billion euros with 1.2 billion of
that coming from the EU every year it's
a vital investments as that you use
chief diplomat federica mogherini
security and development in afghanistan
is key to the region and also to the
international community including
European Union Afghanistan is
Afghanistan needs our help and I believe
it is our duty we will continue to
support the approach Afghanistan has
taken in the past few years Afghanistan
gurgaon you listen inlets Yavin vite
understood ssin money for reforms are
conditioned the u.s. supports but that's
not all this paper reveals a new deal
between the EU and Afghanistan in the
future rejected refugees would be sent
back to Kabul much more easily the EU
would in turn pay the costs for their
reintegration back in Afghanistan human
rights activists around the world and
not least in Afghanistan are critical
saying Afghans have few prospects back
home for the time being if because
securities in and concern for everyone
not only for Refugees so that wouldn't
be there you know they're right
solutions especially for our young
generation the international community
sees the need to keep contributing
especially since it's now feeling its
own burden through the refugee crisis